jen
if a woman is the prize wouldn't that
make the man the simp
someone defines him for me like putting
a woman on a pedestal will smith
hmm
yeah
yeah it wouldn't make them it wouldn't
make a man a simp
so is there something wrong with a man
like admiring his woman yes because most
of the time the woman ends up like kind
of walking over him like jada and it
doesn't really work
so no one has a good example of a man
that does it healthily that without i've
never seen it absolutely
don't know
i've seen healthy yeah so what do you
think jay-z cheated so far
i think there's a difference between
admire it's it's like you can give an
admiration to a girl if she deserves it
but does did jada deserve the admiration
that she's gotten over the years when
she's been giving her kids letters from
tupac
that's crazy when she has her daughter
writing a letter to tupac about how much
her daughter misses him even though i
think she deserves she wasn't even alive
when that's that's what i'm saying
but that's how crazy like jada is to the
family so do you don't you feel like
jade is jade on the mad end of the
spectrum
it's an example it's like okay when we
see some something happen to celebrities
it's indicative of a society
for example amber heard johnny depp
that's extreme right but if that
happened to a man with money power and
privilege what happens to the average
guy so this is happening to will smith
on the big screen again he's got money
power and privilege who has more
leverage than will smith what happens to
the normal guy who's just marrying the
ran through girls someone's got to do it
i thought that like what he said if
there's a healthy type i don't think
there's anything wrong with like a
healthy if you deserve it but the
problem is modern women don't deserve it
because we have nothing that men want
anymore if
not
for them for most average men they don't
know what the the line of healthy
admiration is because in order to keep
the woman they think they just got to do
everything and just go to their beck and
call mm-hmm and we often find it that's
not attractive
so i think she'll find that twenty
percent elsewhere i think if it was
healthy he wouldn't be a simple yeah
yeah okay so this thing means that it's
an unhealthy
if you had to crush yourself to please
somebody would you do as a woman if you
had to crush yourself to please your man
you can identify that that is wrong
right
that applies this way around depends
what do you mean by crush yourself so an
example
i see you looking over there but i would
say you know with simpin
so as a simp you crush yourself you you
you crush who you are to satisfy the
woman that you're with right you put
this woman on a pedestal on
uh
as
a you put yourself
in the position to for her to stand on
you as a like a leaning post she treats
you disregard disrespect and you
continue to do the same thing yes so
you're crushing yourself to satisfy the
woman to be in the presidency okay so
you're talking about the girls like like
bombs basically like they're dating
bombs and then the guys don't have
anything to offer nobody
so even if he has something to offer for
example will smith he didn't have to go
on the stage and embarrass himself like
that then jay the turnaround was like
yeah why did he do that like you're
undermining the man in your life who
you're married to right so if okay let
me reword it but if you have to
undermine yourself to satisfy the woman
you're with you're a simp you're right
but i'm saying like vice versa doesn't
the woman have to give up herself in
order to build a family isn't that
that's part of being a woman yeah but
like you have to undermine yourself like
part of being feminine is letting the
man lead and letting him have the
spotlight but
there's no issue it's about having a
balance between the two parties if you
have to undermine yourself as a man you
can't be a leader you can't have the
vision and the we weren't talking i was
talking about the other way around oh as
a woman yeah so you're saying i i
understand what a cent is other way
around yeah so as a woman
you know
well for me i'll talk for myself
i don't have a problem compromising if
it's for family there's an end goal we
have a goal in mind um if what about
just for a man
but what i wouldn't just do it for a man
there must be a comment but that's
that's the problem wait so is it because
because that that indicates yourself
that you're self-centered because you
wouldn't just do it for a man you have
to get something let me you have to you
have to get something out of it yeah
and and so like if you wouldn't just do
it like you put just for a man yeah but
for a man you have to have actual value
in my life i wouldn't just do it for my
friend i wouldn't just do it for the guy
down the road right i know but in this
conversation we're talking about a guy
you're dating oh okay i think like
that's easy
yeah that's part of the relationship
dynamic you know compromise
understanding having communication
skills this is where you find the
balance between each other to have a
relationship and i think if as a man you
have to divide yourself to be with that
woman she's not for you
most men in today's society have to
undermine themselves to some level to be
desirable to a woman because even
something like monogamy is a man
undermining himself to please a woman
isn't it
well i i wouldn't know you would know
more than i yeah why are men expected to
deal with our hormones when we're on our
period but we're not expected to deal
with men's hormones like i'm being corny
of course you get it that's youtube
so so
because we expect monogamy right
yeah but i think you know in this
society women are hypersexualized so if
you feel no we sexualize ourselves don't
don't put that hypersexualized that like
that word takes accountability off of
women
we sexualize ourselves yeah we do
sexualize ourselves but we are hyper
sexualized in the domain so for me when
i'm looking at women twerking jumping up
and down and then saying oh i'm not
gonna you know beat down on my mind like
how he wants
you're a hypocrite you're you're
hypocrite you're not you're not so no no
really like if a man's asking you you
know babe i need this and you're saying
no well there's 300 other girls in his
dm that will give that to him without
any questions asked so
as i said if you have to undermine
yourself to be with somebody man or
woman
it's not worth it but in terms of our
reproductive strategies yeah a woman's
reproductive strategy is monogamy that's
how you safeguard yourself and and
ensure the future of your offspring for
a man
um we overexpendable like we die and we
go to war and we go out and hunt all
that kind of stuff so our reproductive
strategy is scattergun so we conform to
the female standard to keep his law
happy so we essentially minimize our
biological impulses to make sure that
he's not happy so to that you're
undermining yourself now
well
what is a man as a man yeah well in
society this is what we've accepted as
the norm if you if you've ex could you
say yes or no to the question is he
under are they undermining themselves in
that situation i i'm not in that
position to offer i don't know but i'm
asking you like because a lot of times
like when girls are in a corner they
don't like they don't answer the
question yeah so i i yes or no are you
undermining yourself whether they're
getting ready
yes in the sense of biologically you are
undermining yourself but this is what
we're talking about we're talking about
standards versus biology biology
dictates that boom you can have sex with
100 women get 100 women pregnant
a woman can only be pregnant once a year
her bio biology biology dictates that
basically by the time she's 45 she's
dried up she's no use to the average man
now men are aware of this yeah
biologically and
straight away we know this so it's a
choice that they make to be with that
woman nobody's forcing them to be in
that situation
i wouldn't necessarily say he's
undermining himself but he's making a
conscious decision to look at the women
available on the market as we've
identified low quality
not as a majority but as you so you're
almost flipping your answer yeah you
said yes and now you're saying no what
do you mean do you think a man is
undermining himself no i just need to
answer the question no do i think he's
undermining himself biologically yes but
societally no because he knows the
standards